Let's go to our caller from the six zero nine
area code.
Who is calling today from six Oh nine.
Hey, what packed my total controlling 71 how
you doing?
Good.
What's going on?
All right, so a couple observations here.
Um, I believe that the me too movement has
done more damage to women than help them in
terms of this election cycle.
Uh, I do believe that, I do believe women
have indeed been victimized by men for centuries,
uh, quite rudely in some cases.
But I believe that women in the Mitsu movement
in their newly acquired power to terminate
powerful men on accusation alone.
He said, she said, accusation alone, it's
left than a little power drunk, I think.
And I think that's translating in the polls
and with the voters.
I think that people just simply don't want
to bring in a woman president right now or
at least for this election cycle.
So total control.
Let me see if I understand, because you're
saying a lot, I want to make sure I understand
it.
You're saying that the women can, that it's
currently running, like for example, Elizabeth
Warren or Kama Harris who dropped out or tool
C gabber or Amy Klobuchar.
They would have more support today if men
hadn't lost jobs because of allegations of
sexual assault?
Is that your assertion?
Okay,
no.
My assertion is this women, or to be more
specific, if the me too movement had been
a bit more responsible with their newly acquired
power.
That's what I'm saying.
What's an example of the irresponsibility
of the use of the power of the me too movement?
Well, complete.
Uh, no, no due process.
Like I said, I already said it.
Yeah.
But what's an example of the power being wielded
and what's the, what's a, what's an example
of that power being wielded?
Um, inappropriately?
He said, she said,
right, but what's an example of that?
What is the, if there's something that is
making voter hold on, but total hold on decades
ago.
The me too movement is there.
Hold on.
Total control.
Sorry.
Flores with her hair sniffing claim, that
was pretty crazy.
If I'm not mistaken.
Which store is this?
[inaudible] had a grimace on his face the
entire time that he was pretty much being
forced to cover it.
So you're saying the female democratic candidates
aren't getting more support because of CNN
reporting about Lucy Flores?
No, that's what you're saying.
They, but I've already said what I wanted
to say, but it's pretty obvious that you're
not really happy with what the narrative that
I've crafted here.
And that's okay.
You don't have to, anyway.
How about if we move on to Donald Trump because
I heard a couple of uh, interesting nicknames
for him.
My nickname is agent orange and the PON is
intended.
Okay, good.
Yeah, we've heard that one before total.
All right, total.
We're running low on time.
I'm going to let you go.
Um, okay.
There it is.
Total.
What was the his name?
Total control eight 71.
Very good.
I thank you so much for the calls.
We are, uh, I'm sorry I wasn't able to get
to everybody.
Uh, but we will take calls again and I appreciate
everybody who did call it